so I've got people interested in doing
the natural podcast with me which is
brilliant but I've never done a podcast
before so how am I gonna prepare for it
I did first is what a lot of people
should probably do in today's world and
that's put it in Google so the first
thing I did was put it in Google how do
I prepare for a podcast episode if I'm
interviewing someone or getting someone
on my show and there's loads of stuff on
there loads of really helpful tips but
what I found the most helpful was
another podcast so I listened to a lot
of Tim Ferriss absolutely love his
podcast and he's got millions and
millions of listeners and he actually
did an episode on how to build a podcast
and there's two things that really stuck
out to me which I'm gonna use myself and
intend on doing to prepare for my
podcasts so the first thing is get as
much context as possible
on the person that you're gonna be
getting on a show firstly I think that's
only fair because they're taking time
out of their day to speak to you and I
think that you should know as much as
you can about them and it's gonna help
the conversation it's gonna help the
conversation flow you can bring up
recent the things for them to speak
about so do you research look at them on
social media look at what they've been
talking about and do a bit of that
background research as well so the
second thing what I'm going to be doing
is preparing my questions so when I do
the podcast episode I'm gonna have my
laptop up and have a set of probably 15
to 20 questions that I I could ask the
person now these aren't gonna be I have
to go through the list but questions
that I can lean on because I want the
questions and the conversation to be
natural when the conversations have an
actual flow to it but what the questions
help is that when you're coming to the
end of a particular answer or what
you're speaking about or subject you can
have a quick look at that a quick glance
at the list and not move on to a next
question and so there the two things
that I'm going to be doing
that scares much context and do you
research on the person that you're
getting on your podcast and secondly get
your questions ready that's just going
to make your life easier
allow the conversation to flow naturally
and yeah that's what I'm going to be
doing and I'm sure I'm confident that'll
work out great so that's what I wanted
to share
[Music]